if you've ever taken the time to sit
through the full credits of a movie
you've noticed that it can take
thousands of people to finish a film
which makes it that much funnier when a
glaring mistake sneaks its way past all
of them here are some of the weirdest
funniest and all-around best movie
mistakes that made the final cut
Star Wars head bonk director George
Lucas didn't have the biggest budget to
work with when he made the original Star
Wars so we had to work with some shots
in situations that were less than ideal
one legendary mistake happens when a
bunch of stormtroopers burst into a
Death Star control room one trooper
unable to see well through his helmet
bumps his head on the door Lucas may not
have planned the shoot this way but when
putting together his special edition
years later he didn't take it out
instead he added a sound effect to
acknowledge the GUP else's amazing hair
when you're a Disney cartoon you don't
have to obey the laws of physics
just ask Elsa from frozen during her big
musical number she can flawlessly let
down her hair and she can even send her
braids soaring straight through her arm
without feeling a thing Gotham City's
horrible drivers even before Bane took
over Gotham in the Dark Knight Rises the
city had plenty of problems with
criminals but not just the super-powered
ones when Catwoman steals Bruce Wayne's
car during one of the movies lighter
moments it's amazing to see that
literally no one on the street is
obeying the obvious red light at this
intersection
holy traffic ticket Batman Captain
waterproof and Captain America the
Winter Soldier we see cap diving out of
a plane into the ocean so we can stage a
sneak attack on a ship and when he
climbs out of the water
he's bone-dry shield and all he probably
learned that trick from the Submariner
Batman's incredible bat punch it's easy
to forget how much choreography is
involved in a movie fight sequence but
there's a lot more to it than just
pretending to throw kicks and punches
one wrong move can
difference between a scene that looks
convincing and one that well looks like
the rooftop fight from The Dark Knight
Rises there's a lot going on here
including a fateful turn in the
relationship between Batman and Catwoman
so most of us didn't notice that one of
Bane's henchmen takes a dive during the
fight falling down without anyone even
laying a hand on him the Amazing Spider
lab the best part of having multiple
spider-man reboots is getting to see
Spidey learning how to use his powers
all over again right just kidding it's
the most boring part of the story but in
2002 spider-man
our young heroes training footage comes
with a memorable blooper he breaks a
lamp while testing his webbing but when
Aunt May comes knocking at the door
moments later its back on the Shelf like
nothing ever happened
one possible explanation it was bitten
by a radioactive lampshade another
possible explanation
lazy editors harry potter and the
visible cameraman in one scene from
Harry Potter and the Chamber of Secrets
a tense battle of wands between Harry
and the villainous Draco Malfoy includes
an extra bit of magic in the form of the
muggle cameraman who can be glimpsed
filming after Harry knocks table down
maybe he's there of shooting an MTV
reality series 16 and magic the
mysterious hedge maze Stanley Kubrick's
The Shining is a masterpiece that uses
disorientation to create a growing
feeling of unease in the viewer as
shining experts have pointed out over
the years the movie setting the remote
Overlook Hotel has a floor plan that's
riddled with spatial impossibilities the
weirdness doesn't stop at the hotel
walls either the movies climax makes
brilliant use of a creepy hedge maze
which is nowhere to be seen during the
sweeping aerial shot of the Overlook
that opens the movies unintentional goop
or twisted to Ricky and genius
you decide the little anticipate er one
of the greatest grooves in classic
cinema occurs during this scene from the
vintage Hitchcock thriller North by
Northwest watch the background during
Cary Grant's argument with Eva Marie
Saint specifically when Saints character
pulls a gun on grants a child actor
who'd evidently gotten a case of nerves
after reading the script or suffering
through a few too many takes covers his
ears well before his character is
supposed to be aware of what's going on
Teen Wolf flasher there's no shortage of
cheesy silliness in the mid-80s Michael
J Fox cult comedy classic Teen Wolf
after all it's about a suburban kid who
suddenly realizes he's you know a teen
werewolf not much subtlety in that title
but there's a background extra in the
movies final act who actually is pretty
subtle and who may give you a quick
laugh if you're watching closely the
moment in question occurs during the big
celebration after Fox's character wins
the big game and a celebration erupts in
the stands evidently surprising one
young woman in the crowd who can be seen
cheering with her pants completely
unzipped and unbuttoned she manages to
get them closed up later in the scene
but really let's take a moment to
recognize that a nameless extra managed
to become more interesting than the
wearable who just won a high school
basketball games
give that woman and Oscar the commando
Porsche there are so many questions in
Arnold Schwarzenegger 1980s action
masterpiece commando like why is his big
austrians named John matrix and how is
Alyssa Milano his daughter and more than
anything what's the deal with his magic
yellow Porsche we're talking of course
about the part of the movie that sees
matrix chasing down the bad guys sullied
trashing the Porsche in the process the
car seems destined for a few weeks in a
body shop until John gets back behind
the wheel at which point it appears
miraculously damage free thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one
you just saw and leave us a comment to
tell us your favorite movie mistakes
that should have made the list